so what should Americans demand of
Congress in light of the Twitter file
Revelations unfortunately if a tool of
centralized speech control can be abused
by government it's a virtual certainty
that it will be abused eventually we
should follow the advice of Julian
Assange and the cypherpunk movement that
shaped his thinking which maintained
that technology not government policy is
the only effective check on
authoritarian tendencies in the long run
you cannot trust a government to
implement the policies that it says it
is implementing and so we must provide
the underlying tools cryptographic tools
that we control
as a sort of use of force the good news
is that many people are gradually waking
up to the dangers of allowing a company
to maintain centralized control over the
public conversation